the mistake that a lot of conservatives
have made in the past they're not making
it right now fortunately is they think
that political movements are won by
being the most Centrist type of
candidate you can possibly be and
following the consensus view that's not
how political movements are won
political movements are won by highly
motivated groups of political minorities
who have a very clear Vision who don't
just follow the consensus view but who
craft the consensus view that's how
political movements are one that's how
the libs have won for the last 50 70
years and if conservatives want to start
winning we need that Clarity too without
a Clear Vision if we're just going to be
the Democrats light people are going to
vote for the Democrats Democrats are
much better at being Democrats than we
are